[Musique]
isabelle mollet bonjour bonjour pourquoi
vous présentez vous aux élections
législatives et pourquoi sous la
bannière de l'ue dei pourquoi alors
parce que je suis je fais partie des
personnes qui rouspètent beaucoup parce
que
rien ne va on trouve que rien ne va et
du coup je me suis dit beaulieu danse
péter j'essaye de m'engager
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes un
militant politique alors j'ai commencé
en 2018 avec en 2017 pardon avec
philippe petit pour la mairie de ducos
donc ça correspond à mes idées donc
voilà j'ai voulu continuer avec sous la
bannière de l'ue dit parce que justement
un parti national permet de nous aider
aussi sur le plan de la martinique donc
cet engagement est tout récent avant
2017 vous vous aviez vos opinions mais
vous étiez pas engagé dans un parti ou à
des élections voilà tout à fait
cela fait longtemps que vous vivez en
martinique puisque vous n'êtes pas
originaire de la martinique non ça se
voit
quoique c'est vrai que voilà mais oui je
fasse ça fait 18 ans que je suis en
martinique j'ai vécu également cinq ans
sur saint martin donc je suis
martiniquaise d'adoption et je suis
originaire de lyon est fier de l'être
j'entends parler beaucoup de lyon aussi
en ce moment avec wendy renard par
rapport aux sports je suis moi-même
sportive aussi je vais football féminin
voilà tout à fait un bond au féminin
voilà et j'ai fait moi-même du sport
j'ai fait quinze ans de basket sur lyon
également et je suis une marathonienne
et semi marathon sur fort-de-france
également nos coeurs
alors quels sont les deux ou trois
projets prioritaires si vous étiez élue
députée isabelle mollet que vous auriez
défendu pour le territoire de la
martinique m'a déjà en priorité il ya
les sargasses
il ya le chlordécone aussi il faut
vraiment continuer
toutes les démarches à faire
aussi bien donc pour le club l'heure des
cornes il ya déjà pas mal de progrès
puisque là avec les prises de sang il
faut encourager les gens à aller vers
justement faire leur prise de sang pour
savoir où on en est déjà dans notre sens
puisque c'est un pris en charge par la
sécurité sociale donc il faut vraiment
continuer dans cette démarche pour
essayer de voir pour assainir les sols
donc se rapprocher des scientifiques
enfin vraiment faire des recherches
qu'il faut et vous seriez prêt donc à
monter à la tribune de l'assemblée
nationale pour en parler défendre une
politique donc beaucoup plus efficace en
ce sens et tout pourquoi pas proposer
des amendements à une loi ou un
dispositif qui ferait qu' on irait plus
loin dans ce domaine oui tout à fait
parce qu'en fait il ya la martinique
mais où il ya la même problématique en
bretagne aussi est-ce que le chlordécone
ici mais après
une certaine époque y avait tellement de
pesticides donc en fait on va peut-être
découvrir que toute la france il ya
beaucoup de ces deux territoires qui
sont donc ce qui est valable pour nous
c'est valable pour toute la france quoi
vous pensez aux écocide d'une manière
générale en france peut-être concernant
la situation et les difficultés les
problèmes rencontrés par
la population les électrices et les
électeurs dans votre circonscription ben
là encore quelles seraient vos priorités
isabelle mollet en tant que député si
vous étiez lui et essayer de rassembler
les gens les intergénérations refaire
des groupes de paroles pour voir
justement tout le malaise kia et
pourquoi et à ce malaise essayer de
comprendre et puis il ya beaucoup de
choses à revoir aussi notamment en santé
du malaise chez les fouilles à l'aise et
les foyalais parce qu'on le rappelle
vous présenter dans la troisième
circonscription seul de fort de france
oui bah disons que c'est pas normal
qu'une si belle ville soit une ville
morte comme ça bon moi j'ai eu mon
domaine c'est l'artisanat puisque je
suis artisan d'art de martinique j'ai le
label de qualité aussi de la chambre des
métiers donc baissé en avril faut mettre
en avant cette belle ville c'est une
belle ouverture à la fois pour le
tourisme et pour l'écologie donc c'est à
nous on devrai me montrer l'exemple à la
métropole ça serait une fierté de
montrer que nous mais on puisse montrer
l'exemple en conclusion qu'avez vous à
dire d'essentiel pour convaincre
justement les électrices et électeurs
foyalais même moi j'essaye de convaincre
je suis quelqu'un de terrain puisque je
suis en martinique donc depuis 18 ans à
mon compte en tant qu'artisans
depuis quinze ans je suis au coeur du
problème ne serait ce que aussi par
rapport à
l'octroi de mer ou moi en tant que petit
artisan et en tant qu' on va dire
transformer la matière première c'est
très compliqué le système de l'octroi de
mer donc frais je pense que c'est tout à
revoir c'est tout un système à revoir ne
pas dire que il faut plus d'être trop
nerveux ye a besoin de cet octroi de mer
mais faut vraiment tout modifier
l'octroi de mer donc
pour moi il faut qu'on se rassemble et
votez pour moi pour le 11 juin merci
isabelle mollet
[Musique]